man-on-the-street comedy that's
something that late-night shows have
been doing since back in the 1950s you
know I'm talking about you you put a
camera in someone's face the ask him
about history or politics they can't
answer the question they got all
flustered
everyone laughs cuz it's amazing what
people don't know it's our chance to
just feel good about ourselves and laugh
at others we thought you know we never
really did much of that we thought we
should start doing it now after all
these years so we did why not it's gonna
be a lot of fun take a look how does
Congress pass a budget let's see the
congressional appropriations committee
presents a bicameral Budget
Reconciliation as for the Congressional
Budget Act of 1974 and what did the 2011
Budget Control Act do impose caps on the
level of discretionary appropriation and
what is the Byrd rule it prohibits the
Senate from considering extraneous
matters as part of a reconciliation bill
pursuant to the exceptions in Section
313 be its section 313 B - to what David
the u.s. declare war against Japan
December 8 1941 at what time
well Congress passed the declaration at
1:10 eastern standard time but FDR
signed the declaration at 4:10 and what
was the written agreement formalizing
the surrender of Japan the Japanese
instrument of surrender and where did
this render take place oh that was on my
grandpa's ship the deck of the USS
Missouri which was also known by its
nickname mighty moe it's actually big
moe
how do constitutional amendments get
ratified through congressional vote or a
state convention which Supreme Court
case addressed how long Congress has to
ratify an amendment call me Miller which
set precedent for the 27th amendment in
which three other pending amendments the
congressional apportionment amendment
the title of nobility Amendment and the
Corwin amendment hey my grandpa wants to
talk to you our ship was mighty moe I'm
sure that I was there okay Gramps this
little thing called Wikipedia would beg
to differ
man I saw thousands of my brothers in
arms' perish in that war but we knew the
price of our lives was worth the freedom
that you enjoyed today I think that
demands a little respect to my fellow
veterans and I incorrect it's my fellow
veterans and me
[Applause]